I was reading also who got the money
from the paytech Protection Program
you know this is our 800 billion dollars
that's kind of a lot okay that we gave
out
only about a quarter of the money spent
by the program paid wages that would
have otherwise been lost
so three quarters of it didn't do of 800
billion and then 72 percent
of the relief money ended up in the
hands of people with incomes household
incomes in the top 20 percent I think
this is what the truckers are mad at not
that they know the exactly but 20 20 all
that money end up the people who are in
the top 20 percent those the people who
got loans for 1.5 million dollars and
over got a quarter of the money
this is so outrageous Donald Trump's
personal lawyer his Law Firm got a 10
million dollar loan this is what people
are angry at because the system is so
corrupt right the system is so corrupt
and it's not just corporate Elites it's
the corporate Elites who are corrupting
the system because of the money that
corporations they're under influence on
a very very corrupt government this
corruption is so baked into the cake and
of course people are angry people are
enraged and they are legitimately
enraged it's so baked into the cake that
is bipartisan it is bipartisan in that
right absolutely but if there are
differences big differences we may
didn't agree about that I think there
are a big difference between Democrats
and Republicans but this kind of stuff
they're kind of on the same team
Republican started it but the Democrats
haven't stopped it right and at this
point the Republicans don't even pretend
to care and the main difference between
the Democrats is that they do pretend to
care this has to do that's the main
difference between the parties at this
time
when you look at those people who could
afford to stay home with their
Lululemon's what has happened with this
what what is that it's interesting to
note without PPP alone uh data the small
business administration tried to keep it
secret they said because of privacy they
didn't want to let out the numbers and
the judge said oh no the people need to
know this and made those numbers public
so what's happening is the people are
getting the receipts for what we have
been feeling for so long this kind of
economic Injustice this kind of
structural rigging so that whenever
there's a problem take care of the
people who already have and then the
rest of people who don't have well good
luck will drop a few crumbs to you it's
been going on for decades people have
felt it they've acted on it and now
we're getting the receipts
we sent our stimulus check back there is
no there's a there's a economic stimulus
check we got we send it back this is not
meant for people like us but I think
that actually the at the end of the day
this is about a merger of government and
private Enterprise that together is
actually far more dangerous than either
one BlackRock the world's largest asset
manager managing over 10 trillion
dollars got the deal to administer much
of the covid-19 stimulus and many of
their alumni now staffed the
administration and so I think that this
is you're right it's not a left-wing
issue it's not a right-wing issue it is
a rejection of this marriage of the
private sector and government you know
we live in the moment of social
distancing what I think is actually we
need more social distancing between
capitalism and democracy let the private
sector operate let government operate
keep them apart from it
there is a word for it when government
is so tied is so married to corporate
interests that word is fascism right
amen that is the actual definition of
fascism
foreign